Tim: Our next lecture topic is: Churchill
as a defender of constitutionalism. To address
that topic please welcome the 12th president
of Hillsdale College, Dr. Larry P. Arnn.
Larry: Thank you. Good morning. Can everybody
hear okay? I’ve come to learn in recent
years that nobody can hear me when I talk
and that's one reason why I'm popular. To
people in the front I've heard them talk to
the people in the back, and the people in
the front say, “No, he wasn’t that good.”
Thank you Tim. This popped into my mind while
Tim was talking. Tim played football at Hillsdale
College a little bit. He didn’t keep playing.
I asked him why because as you can see he’s
a really big guy and he said well he was more
academically inclined. John Cervini who was
an All-American football player at Hillsdale
College gives a different account of why he
didn’t play so much. They were both really
great students.
I said last night that the study of Churchill
and the few people who are like him is a good
thing for everybody to do. I said that it's
a good thing for our college to do because
of its interest in civil and religious freedom.
I said that everybody needs to know what statesmanship
is. I'm going to try to put these arguments
together and tell you what I think Churchill
was about in his life, and I'll mention his
interest in constitutionalism along the way.
At the beginning I want to make two distinctions.
One is between constitutionalism and statesmanship.
Actually on the other order, the one is what
do statesmen do, what is their gift, what
faculty do they exercise? We learn in the
classic books that the gift that we have for
choosing is called prudence. Prudence is a
contradictory thing. It involves two things
at the same time. One is what we aim for,
what we love, what we seek. The other is all
the circumstances around us. Those two things
get in the way of each other all the time.
If you have children, they play the clarinet,
or they sing in the choir, or they play soccer
or basketball and you want to go. But also
you got to work. You have clients. There’s
a man in this room today who's a chief engineer
at NASA and the rockets might blow up if he
didn’t go to work. So he's got a pick. Both
of those things are absolute commitments.
You make contract with somebody. You’re
supposed to do what you say. Give birth to
a child. You’re supposed to take care of
the child. But the two things compete with
each other in time and you got to try to solve
that problem.
The way I solved it was marrying above myself.
My wife is so nice that she can be nice to
everybody, all at the same time, including
the children especially. But that's the kind
of thing.
Here’s a choice that Churchill made. It
gets to be 1940. He becomes Prime Minister
on the day Hitler comes to the West. The war
had been slow in the West up until that day.
But that day the government had broken the
day before. Churchill who was a member of
the government that broke had defended the
Prime Minister and then he becomes Prime Minister
and he reads that the German army is coming.
May the 10th, 1940 is the day he became Prime
Minister and the German army comes in a hurry.
France, one of the greatest nations in the
world with one of the largest armies in the
world falls in about six weeks. Churchill
watches all that happen. Over the course of
about 18 days the British come to understand
that they're going to have to fight the Germans
by themselves.
Germany by the way is in league at this time
with Soviet Russia, so it's both of them.
The British have nothing. I mean they have
10 divisions, something like that. The Germans
have about 300. They're going to be alone.
The ones who got back from Dunkirk this unfolds,
that's over by June the fourth, 1940, they
didn't get back with their heavy equipment.
So his first choice is, are we going to keep
on? Are we going to fight this thing, by ourselves?
Really? That's not a choice that in politics
as in life, by the way, you can just say,
“Well, I think this is best or I think that
is best.” Whatever you come up with you’re
going to have to fight for it, because in
the British political system as in the American
at least before Obama, there's no one person
who just gets to make up his mind and that's
it.
Sure enough about 10 days after Churchill
became Prime Minister they start hearing from
Mussolini who's not in the war yet. He says,
“We could have a peace conference, and Italy
would agree to host the peace conference and
put it together.” Of course they want something
for that. Who knows? Maybe Gibraltar, maybe
something in Africa. The thing is they’re
going to be overwhelmed. Sure enough the foreign
minister, Edward Halifax likes the idea of
this thing.
You have to stop a minute and think everything
that happened after made the 28th, 1940 when
this came to a head, everyone who died who
was British and everyone who was killed by
a British person, and you could also say by
extension everyone who died who was an American
or who was killed by an American. That history
stems from the choice they made on that day.
Because they might have started their peace
conference and then Britain would not be invaded
or bombed as it was. It was almost invaded
and it was bombed. Churchill is in a place
where he's got to take responsibility for
that.
Churchill by the way is desperately afraid
of war all his life. I'll tell you about that
in a minute. You've got to think, we're getting
creamed here. If there's a way not to go through
all this, wouldn't that be better? That's
what Edward Halifax thought. He was a serious
man, a good man. Wrong I think sometimes in
more important ways, but good. So what’s
he to do?
You remember that in the summer of 1940 he
made a speech that ends with, “If the British
Empire should last a thousand years, men will
still say this was their finest hour.” It’s
a beautiful thing to write. He wrote that
himself and many other very beautiful things.
If you ask the question, by the way, who's
waiting in the wings who’s like Winston
Churchill? Read and listen, because boy, he
could write and he could speak. He really
could. The people today mostly it's a different
kind of thing. Although some of them are getting
better.
Here's what he did on the 28th of May, 1940.
The war cabinet seems divided. There are five
people in it. Halifax seems like he wants
to make some kind of a deal, and they've been
arguing about it for a few days. But they
don't bring it to conclusion because if Churchill
said, “I'm adamant that we won't do this,”
and then Halifax resigned, which he might,
a point of principle, a big thing, and that's
the style in Britain, then probably the government
would fall and then Churchill would be out
of power. So he couldn't order them.
What he did was there was a cabinet meeting.
He got a cabinet meeting together that day.
That's a bigger body. There were five in the
war cabinet and they were 40 or so in the
cabinet. I don’t actually know the number
of that. Richard Langworth does. He knows
all those numbers.
Andrew: 28.
Larry: 28?
Andrew: My name’s Andrew.
Larry: Oh Andrew is sitting right there. Yeah,
so Andrew there were 28. As I was saying there
were 28. One of Churchill's favorite sayings
was if you keep a dog you don't have to bark
yourself. I
got my two yappers sitting right down there.
We're going to do fine in this speech today.
So they're 28. He talks about an hour. The
best notes are by a man named Hugh Dalton.
He was a labor minister and very left and
also liked Churchill, always did. Here's how
Churchill ended. First of all he draws a picture
of the war. He says, “The French are going
to quit. We're going to get thrown off. We
don't know what we're going to get back. Then
there's going to be a battle in the Channel.
We have a navy. Hard to beat that navy, but
on the other hand air power is probably going
to decide,” and they had more airplanes.
On the other hand, third-hand, “Most of
the battles would be over Britain and we'll
have an advantage. We've done pretty well
in the initial air battle, so we got to fight
it out,” he says.
This is what the thing is going to look like.
It's very bleak. Nobody's saying we're going
to maneuver over here and go there and then
get to Berlin. They're saying how are we going
to survive. Then he says, “I've been thinking
in these last few days whether it is part
of my duty to open negotiations with that
man.” He doesn’t mention that there's
a definite proposal to do that in front the
war cabinet. “And I believe that if I were
for a moment to consider parlay or surrender,
every one of you would rise up and tear me
down from my place. If this island story is
to end at last, let it end when each of us
lies choking in his own blood upon the ground.”
Now by the way, that’s a heck of a thing
to say. There was a demonstration, there was
wild applause, and Halifax thought maybe when
they resumed the war cabinet that they would
be on a slippery slope if they were to begin
these negotiations.
Now what I want you to understand is two things.
One is in principle that choice is just like
the choice you make whether you go to the
concert or the ball game on the one hand or
do your job on the other. It's a choice between
competing goods. The second one is Churchill
was the kind of guy who put himself in the
place to make choices like that and thought
he was made for such choices.
That choice is extremely consequential, because
there's a conservative-leaning historian name
Charmley. Is he still around Andrew? You see
him? Yeah. I don't like him very much, but
he's pretty smart. He wrote a book in which
he blames the decline of Britain on that choice
that day and says that they should’ve made
it different. Churchill himself when he says,
“If the British Empire should last a thousand
years, men will still say this was their finest
hour,” he's trading the thousand years for
that day. That's a serious choice. Did he
make it right? That's a question. Just like
all of your choices, that's a question.
Now that led when he introduced this funny
thing about statesmanship and constitutionalism,
because they’re opposites, aren’t they?
At the time Churchill reached his glory because
he became the greatest man in the world, and
he was treated that way, although people voted
against his party in 1945. Everybody treated
him for the rest of his life like wow what
a man and he'd never had that before.
At that time the great world statesmen were
of course the ones you know. They were Adolf
Hitler and Joseph Stalin and Franklin Roosevelt.
What were their opinions about constitutions?
They had the statesmen’s opinion about constitutions.
All of them thought, “Heck, there's a lot
to do. We can't be concerned with old rules
that are made a long time ago before our circumstances.”
Constitution, that's what it's like. Every
law is supposed to be a general statement,
made in advance, applying to all, and easy
to understand, made before you know who's
going to be hurt by it. We don't make laws
that way. We make rules now that actually
name, by name often who's going to be benefited
and who's goings to be harmed. But the rule
of law means that laws are made in general
and in advance and without respecting the
persons who’ll be affected.
Constitutions are the biggest kinds of laws.
A person who's good at making choices like
that, because what Churchill did on the 28th
of May 1940 was no normal thing. Because the
whole world is falling apart around his ears
and he's wanted that job. He said so since
he was in his 20s. Now at last he's got it
and this is what he has to decide. He has
written, I will tell you. He has written this
in 1925, “Mankind has never been in this
position before. Without improving appreciably
in virtue or enjoying wiser guidance, he has
got into his hands at last the means of his
own destruction. Death stands waiting at attention,
silent expectant, waiting for a word from
the frail being, so long his servant, now
for once is master.”
That's what Churchill thought about war. He
thought that about war since he saw the Battle
of Omdurman in 1898 the Charles Krauthammer
mentioned last night. He was horrified by
that battle and he thought, “Gracious sakes,”
in this war where he won his glory, the Second
World War he’s asking in the middle of it,
“What are we going to call this one war,”
and he said, “That's easy, this is the unnecessary
war. This should have been prevented. I tried
to prevent it.” He doesn't want this thing,
and yet, all these other people who have failed
to prepare for fear of war in part, that's
what Stanley Baldwin said, they're not as
eloquent as Churchill about the dangers of
war. Now the war is upon them and some of
those same people are thinking it's time to
quit.
You can't write a constitution that takes
account of those circumstances. What you need
to take account of out those circumstances
is some extraordinary human being. What he
did see it wasn't enough because it was like
a very grand political maneuver that he pulled
off. Because these guys, the people are Neville
Chamberlain, Edward Halifax, Arthur Greenwood,
Clement Attlee, those two are socialists in
much in the minority in the House of Commons
and no friends of Churchill's except during
the war they were, and Churchill. These two
conservatives, they control the votes. If
they leave the government's gone. What he
does is go to a wider audience and make them
a speech and a heck of a speech, which by
the way is a rare important one that he didn’t
write out in advance. He's responsible for
that. You couldn't decide that by constitutions.
James Madison says about our Constitution,
he says, “Enlightened statesmen will not
always be at the helm,” and so we're going
to need grand laws that keep things steady
and encourage good behavior, inform our characters.
Madison then is like Churchill because Madison
was an inventor of a nation along with his
friends who wrote the Constitution. They wrote
a constitution in which they did not get latitude
to do whatever they wanted.
Whereas Hitler, do you know how Hitler came
to power? In about 1910 he was a street bum,
living rough. He learned to make speeches
ranting around open fires in the street about
the Jews, didn't like those Jews. But by 1925
he's been in the army and the army is behind
him now in politics and he's becoming an important
guy. He never rises above the rank of Corporal.
Then in 1931 and 32 and 33 is when this happened,
he gets in front of General Hindenburg, the
great hero, the senior German military officer
of modern times and now the president the
Weimar Republic. Hindenburg says, “We want
to invite you to form a government.” Hitler,
little corporate Hitler says, “Can't do
it unless you agree that we can pass a law
that my cabinet can do anything it wants to
do.” There must be no constitution. Of course,
why, because he says, “This is an emergency
and I must be allowed to do whatever I want.”
Churchill is the same kind of man, because
if you look on May 28th, 1940, what did he
do? I mean it is stunning what he did, and
he is responsible for that thing, and he wanted
to be. It wasn't enough. If he'd sat there
like the rest of them wringing his hands and
saying, “Well, it's this thing or that and
the war could be very bad and all that stuff.”
He didn't. He got a bunch of people at Rome
and he told them, “It might well mean the
death of everyone sitting here, but we'd better
do this thing.”
If you want to why, he says that in the Munich
speech. It’s by the way a primer in political
science. The whole speech is one of the greatest
political speeches ever given in life, in
history. First of all he says, “What I cannot
bear is the sense of us following under the
orbit and the influence of these Nazis.”
Then toward the end of the speech he says,
“You,” and this is Aristotle’s way of
thinking, he says, “You must consider the
character of the Nazi regime and the rule
which it implies. What kind of people are
they? What do they do? Doesn’t by the way
the world cry out right now for some statesmen
to say that these Iranians and these Chinese
are brutal rulers, and if you disagree with
them they will put you in the pokey for doing
that or they will cut off your head? That
is the character of the regime and the rule
that they imply. They are arming.” Churchill
says in 1936, “There are really only two
facts, Germany is Hitler's and Germany is
arming.”
A man able to do things like that. In politics
he was just the same way as he was on a battlefield.
He was a very lethal human being. He kept
his nerve. He could think. That's what's most
dangerous. People get excited and they crash
around and they charge, “Mad” Anthony
Wayne in the bat- He was wounded one time.
Anthony Wayne, a general in the American Revolutionary
Army, Wayne County, Detroit is named after
him. He’s a very great man. What did he
do?
He got all head up about the British, he was
fighting them, and he's riding around and
he gets up against one of their bunkers and
he can't contain himself. He lift off his
horse over the bunker in amongst the British
and they stabbed him. It was a stupid thing
to do. He was angry. He thought George Washington
was the bravest man he ever saw, because George
Washington was thinking when he was fighting.
That by the way is the meaning of the term
courage. It is not your fear which you must
feel that tells you what to do. It is your
noggin which is still operating. That's what
kind of a guy he was.
So why in 1936 would this guy write an article
about American politics? The article is called
“What good’s the Constitution” and it's
about the court packing scheme. It’s published
in 1935 in Britain and in 1936 in America.
What he says is the Supreme Court has struck
down the National Recovery Act, which by the
way gave the White House and its agency power
to set wages and prices and allocate goods
everywhere in the society. He says, “We
British look at that is kind of odd because
there isn't any court that can do that,”
but he says, “I,” and see Franklin Roosevelt,
what did he say, he, I hasten to say Churchill
admired Roosevelt and he called him the greatest
foreign friend of Britain that Britain ever
hand, but here in 1936 he's taking issue with
him. He says, “The difference between constitutional
rule and not having it is the difference between,”
this is a favorite formulation of his, “between
nations which own peoples and peoples which
own nations. Or government which own peoples
and peoples who own governments.”
That's curious. What I think about him then
is that he loved to rule and he wished to
rule under law. In these hard times you need
somebody lethal. Ronald Reagan was a lethal
guy. He was an actor. What would you think
right? But I know the man who took the Prime
Minister of Bermuda in to see Ronald Reagan
that led to the Granada and an invasion. Eugenia
Charles was her name and the ambassador William
Middendorf, friend of mine today. Middendorf
here's her story and he says, “I'm going
to take you to the White House.” They get
in and they sit and Reagan doesn't say very
much. He had an executive temper. He didn't
blather on. He didn't argue with all the people
who right up to the minute he got out of the
limousine told him not to say the words tear
down this wall. He never argued with any of
them. It's just he was getting ready to be
standing up there giving a speech and he could
say whatever he pleased.
George Schultz put somebody in the limo with
him to urge him at the last minute not to
say that. You see, with this thing, Middendorf
tells me, he didn't make a bunch of speeches.
What he said was, “Okay, I understand.”
He said, “I'll be back to you tomorrow about
this.” 24 hours later we were on our way
there. That’s the executive temper. It’s
the opposite of the law temper in so many
ways. You need both.
It's like the virtue of prudence, isn’t
it? Because when you choose all the time … By
the way, don't you doubt your choices all
the time? I have a job where I make a million
of them. I’m blessed with my friends I work
with, because I can see what's right in their
faces. Sometimes Wayland says this about me,
sometimes I'll be talking and what I want
them to do is smile or not because then I’ll
know I'm going down the right road. If they
don't … Churchill had friends like that,
right? But when you decide and commit yourself
to action, that's the other part of prudence.
There's something in you that doubts, something
that's different from you, something that's
different from what you do that sits in judgment
upon what you do, in your own soul and in
the souls of others. You have to listen that.
Envy in the executive branch, lethal in action.
That means by the way the relationship between
the particular actions of a statesman and
a constitution is like the relationship inside
the soul that takes account of all the circumstances
that play, and also takes account of something
ultimate that's quite beyond you. When you're
dealing with somebody like Adolf Hitler, because
that guy needs killing, and it's going cost
millions of lives to kill him unless you do
it first and early. Churchill had so much
to do with his killing. Yet, because Churchill
heard that voice that was not the same thing
as his will, he was not in need of that killing.
I want to say that I think Winston Churchill
was a humble man. I mean Mr. Singer was really
good and he conveyed something of Churchill's
amazing cockiness. You’re a worm. Yes. We're
all worms. Yes, but I'm glowworm. But you
don't find Churchill standing up giving long
speeches about himself. He writes about things
he does a lot. The first person personal pronoun
is uncommon and hardly ever directly praised.
When he’s dealing with Neville Chamberlain
later which he dealt with him, one of the
most beautiful things he ever wrote is a eulogy
to Neville Chamberlain. Neville Chamberlain
died in 1940, not long after he lost the Premiership.
Churchill admired him and respected him, and
he was generous with him. Churchill didn't
count coup over him and his kind in any obvious
way. He says, “We got to write that off.
We all have reason to search our speeches
and see when we've been right. Now we're one
country and we're going to fight this guy.”
I want to say a word about the Empire. Churchill
was an imperialist and India was the big question.
Lots of good people think that Churchill was
foolish to fight against India in the early
1930s because it lost him credibility against
Hitler. Richard Langworth hosts debates about
that all the time. I'm a partisan in those
debates.
But here's what I think. I think Churchill
thought that the right has got to become very
mighty in the modern world in order to defend
itself. I think he thought that Britain was
in a providential place about that. Because
you know especially the Indian part of the
British Empire, and the big ones are Australia,
Canada, New Zealand, South Africa, what am
I leaving out? West Indies. And those big
ones were really governing themselves by early
in Churchill's day. But India was different.
The British got it by happenstance. India
had a million and a half men under arms on
the British and American side in the First
World War and two and a half million in the
Second World War. It made Britain great, big.
Their casualty rates in the Second World War
were significantly higher than the British,
and they were volunteers by the way. Britain
didn't have the power to make them do it.
In India they were ruling India, but the Indian
Army was entirely volunteer. Churchill thought
we're going to have to be a great power to
defend ourselves and this helps.
But that, you see, because by the way, if
all they are is like the Spartans and the
Athenians, just telling them what to do and
ruling them by force, what becomes of Churchill's
vaunted and oft-repeated claims that everyone
has a right to govern himself, that the petition
of right and the Magna Carta and the petition
and the …. Sorry, I got to get my order
right, the Magna Carta and the English Bill
of Rights and the American Declaration of
Independence are the great title deeds of
the rights of man. What comes of that if they’re
just using India so they can be strong?
China is all wrapped up in the Middle East
right now, and we know what China governs.
Five years ago they published their … every
seven or 10 year major paper on the meaning
of democracy and what were their identities.
We have that now, democracy means that the
party decides in the interest to the people,
and then we can steer the society to some
perfection later.
What will they do with their imperial influence
in the Middle East? How will they treat those
people? What advantages are they going to
get from it? Because they’re spending a
lot of money there now. Why is Iran occupying
five capitals right now in the Middle East?
What are they going to get from that? What
are they going to do with that? You can tell
if you look at the way they treat their own
people. Is Britain like that? Is that what
they were guilty of, as was claimed by many
people and is claimed by many historians today?
Here's what he said. It's interesting what
he said you see because that part of the world
matters a lot and a lot it's going on there,
and between here and there in the Middle East
and power is at stake. Churchill said, “We
got India in a massive act of neglect.”
It actually was conquered by a man named Clive
who was a clerk in a British East India Company.
Then it was given to the Queen. Now we've
got it, and we've been good for it, and the
Indians are accepting of our rule. We don't
have to shoot people. In the one big instance
where they did Churchill condemned the general.
We don't have many people over there. It's
very good for them and we've established the
rule of law. That means they're on their way
to self-government. We get things for it that
are really great. It would be wrong to think
of the Empire as just good for those who are
governed. It can be good for the mother country
too, as long as it's good for both.
Then he says, “Their population has quadrupled,
but there are three things about it that mean
that if we give them self-rule there’s going
to be hundreds of thousands or millions killed.
One of them it's a whole collection of lots
of different peoples who don't speak the same
language. One of them is those two are broadly
divided into Muslim and Hindu. If we leave
they're going to kill each other. The third
one is in Hinduism there's the caste system,
untouchables at the bottom, the Dalits.”
He says, “If we leave that's going to get
worse.”
By the way there's a really good book written
by a journalist, an Indian man who lives in
England now called “Modern India.” He
says in there that there's data that shows
that for the first 15 years of home rule in
India after the Second World War the caste
system was solidified and people were for
it. Churchill says, “We are responsible
for all this, and if we leave we’ll be responsible
for the deaths.” And the deaths are estimated
700,000 to a million when they left. Of course
the Muslims and the Hindus split from each
other in Pakistan and India, and that's part
of the problem in the world right now. He
said, “We should stay and be confident in
our principles of freedom.”
I'm not telling you that because I think he
was right about that. It's a long time now.
India by the way is possibly a massive and
wonderful ally, and thank God for their direction,
and Mr. Modi. But what I want you to know
is Churchill never doubted their capacity
for self-government and never said they didn't
have it. Even often asserted that they did.
There was a plan for the world which he thought
Britain and the United States were obliged
to make because of the goodness of their principles
which had given rise to their strength. Sure
enough we’re governed today by people who
doubt the goodness of our principles and our
country and are dissipating our strength.
My last points about domestic policy. I think
Churchill thought that the things that had
made war more dangerous were the same things
that made politics more dangerous than they
had been before. Both had always been very
dangerous. No more he thought. What were those
things? War had been transformed he said by
science. That is to say we can just make weapons
to slaughter. It’s getting cheap to kill
people. Our societies are much richer and
they can afford to slaughter each other for
longer. They used to run out of food in the
earlier wars and they couldn't campaign in
the winter, because they couldn’t get men
around and they couldn’t sustain them in
the field. Now we can fight all the time and
for years. We have these amazing weapons and
they're getting stronger and stronger.
But these weapons which are so powerful, like
this thing, this is my iPhone. I never go
anywhere without it. It's liberating and makes
it easier for me to run the college and stay
in touch, make the kids stop being naughty
even from a distance. That power, we love
that power, and it makes us healthier, and
it makes us richer, and it makes our lives
more comfortable. We can save people that
might have died earlier, our loved ones.
But now the idea Churchill said is that we
should apply that power to the governing of
other human beings. We should take this science
that is transforming everywhere everything
and we should use it to plan how we govern
people because we could perfect the society.
Churchill publishes a novel in 1898 and in
the novel there's a communist name of Karl
with a K. It's a cool … I love the novel
myself. I also think it's one of Churchill’s
greatest autobiographical works. He's in it
by the name of Savrola. There’s a beautiful
woman named Lucile which means light and she's
the wife of the despot who rules the place.
Savrola at the end of the novel gets the state
and he gets Lucile, he gets the girl.
You see what that means? That means she is
a symbol of the state. The way she's treated
by three people who are two quarters show
how everybody will be treated depending on
who rules the state. Her husband Molara the
despot they have a discussion about beauty.
By the way Churchill is just a kid and he
writes this stuff. It’s extremely interesting
to me. I think he knew what he was doing.
Molara, the despot says, “Beauty is only
fashion, it's just whatever we think it is,
it changes from time to time.” If you think
about that for a minute, if you think you
have the power to define what is beautiful,
which means by the way also by extension the
lower think what is good, then you're a very
powerful man. Molara, the despot is interested
in power.
Now her other suitor is Karl, the socialist.
His buddy says, “What does the Savrola know
of the community of property,” and his friend
unnamed says, “Or the community of wives.
I'd like to have the president's wife.”
She overhears that and shudders. Now do you
think that's a serious point? It might be
because the family is a terrible source of
inequality. There’s a young woman that lives
in Austin, Texas. She is brilliant and she
is beautiful. I commonly refer to her as the
most important young academic in America today.
That's kind of an insult to people because
I employ a whole bunch of young academics
at Hillsdale College, but none of them is
named Kathleen Arnn, and none of them is as
good looking as she is, and none of them is
as fine as she is. By the way she is mine
and I favor her. It would be wrong if I took
college resources to favor her, and I don't
do that, but I wish I could.
You see how that makes things unequal, because
whatever I am is at her disposal. She's the
headmaster of a charter school. They're eight
of them now and they’re soon going to be
13. Which one of them can call me any night
of the week and get the best advice I've got
to give? I know something about that kind
of thing. So if you're going make everything
really equal by science Churchill is saying
and he later says this explicitly in his speeches,
then what you would do is you would get rid
of the family.
Molara says, “Beauty is just whatever we
make of it,” so she can have the socialist
for a husband and then she's going to be everybody's
property, or she can have her husband for
a husband and he says, “Beauty is just whatever
I say it is.” She asked him, “Really?
There's no standard of beauty outside you?”
She asked him that and he insults her because
she's a beautiful woman by saying, “No,
none whatsoever.” Do you see what he took
from her? That's how she's going to live if
she stays married to him.
Savrola says, “Yes, fashion is a thing and
it changes all the time, but look at that
statue,” and he points to a replica of a
Greek statue and he says, “Men have called
that beautiful for 2000 years.” That means
Savrola does not claim that he can say what
is beautiful.
What if it's true that we teach our kids today
in school that anything they think it's true
is true because the standards of truth are
shifting all the time? On what ground then
would you say to any power that your use of
that power is wrongful? I'm saying Winston
Churchill figured that out when he was a boy.
I think the knowledge of that is why he was
able to kill Hitler. I think that's why he
saw socialism for what it was from the first
minute he looked at it.
In 1931 he says carrying on this theme about
the family. By the way, have you read what's
happening to the family in the world? Let's
say we're all important people. We’re here.
I'm an important guy, right? I'm going to
get old and die. Whom am I going to want around
me? What is my real domain? My family and
my friends. I happen to have a lot of friends,
I’m lucky about that. That means honors
and stations and things like that. Those are
important, those matter. But what matters,
did you hear somebody asked Barry Singer about
Churchill's children. Churchill was heartbroken
about his children, many times, and he loved
them very much. He did spoil them.
In 1931 he said, “You know, we're going
to get the power to make babies the way we
want them. And when we do, we're going to
make some of them better and we’re going
to make some of them worse. The worse ones
will use to work for us. And we’ll breed
them so they won't mind, and we’ll do this
in laboratories.” He wrote this in the same
year that Brave New World was published, although
it looks like he only read it in 1958. He
wrote that to his wife in that year.
You see what's possible if you just take science,
if you redefine science away from to know
and to control, which is what it means in
many uses today, and you make that sovereign.
Then why can't you just remake humanity into
whatever you want? That's what Hitler wanted.
That's what Stalin wanted.
In The Wall Street Journal two weeks ago two
Nobel prize-winning biochemists published
an article calling for a moratorium on changing
what's called the germline in DNA. That's
the line that is transmitted from one generation
to the next. The minute we alter it, and there
are things that we can do to it now that will
remove at least one hereditary disease. But
he said the minute, these two scientists,
“The minute we alter it, then it becomes
an artifact, it becomes something we have
made.” I'm using my terms now. Then what
are the limits on how we alter it? In other
words, this thing that Churchill says since
1931 is going to happen, that's a practical
issue alive today.
What I think is amazing about Winston Churchill
is how much he could see and how well he could
explain it. Coolidge said that great statesmen
are the ambassadors of providence sent to
reveal to us our unknowns selves. I think
Churchill is such a messenger, and I think
we should study him. Thank you.
Does anybody want to say anything? Yes sir.
Hi Ross.
Ross: I’ll tell you what. I’ll make this
very short so you could go longer. I'll make
a statement. You tell me why I'm right or
wrong. Comparisons between Barack Obama and
Neville Chamberlain are unfair to Neville
Chamberlain. Tell me if I'm right or wrong
and why?
Larry: Chamberlain's personal habits were
humble and self-restraint. I think I am interested
what Richard and Andrew think about this because
they know a lot about it. I think Churchill
actually disliked Stanley Baldwin, although
he found him witty and charming. Chamberlain
stiffened up when he was around Churchill,
but at the end they became warm to each other.
Chamberlain did something very foolish. The
way Churchill explained it was he was deceived
and misguided in his greatest hopes by a wicked
man.
I don't think Obama like Dick Cheney said
last last week something that I think Krauthammer
hinted at last night but he didn't say it.
I’ll say what I thought he meant but mark
it down that I don't know that this is what
he meant. I think what Cheney said was it's
possible that Obama means harm to our country.
I do think it's true he doesn't like the kind
of thing it has been. It's his own statement
that he means to transform it and thinks that
Lincoln and Reagan are great transformers,
and he's going to transform them. That means
he's going to undo what they did, and therefore
be like them. I think that's his model. I
think that model is like Molara, the tyrant
in Savrola’s model. He's going to make things
the way they want them and he’s going to
make them different so everybody can know
that it's the way they want them.
Harry Jaffa used to say, the great man, he
used to say that God made a promise to the
Jews after the flood that he would not let
them be destroyed. That's why Hitler wanted
to kill them, just to show who's the boss
here now. I worry about that kind of thing.
It's hard for me to think that a man could
take the office of President of United States
and mean harm to the country. I guess I don't
assert that for myself right now. But I wonder
about it, and I do think that he doesn't like
the kind of thing it has been. That's clear
enough.
Speaker 5: Could you clarify Churchill's relationship
to Gandhi? Did he really dislike him and say
the things that are quoted about him, please?
Larry: Well he did call him half-naked fakir
or faqir, striding up the steps of Government
House and he did dislike him. During the Second
World War Gandhi went on hunger strike and
Churchill would sent memos saying, “Is he
still alive? Did somebody sneak him food?
Try to find out.” He was pretty tough about
that. What Churchill thought afterwards was
different because when he was in this fight
here's what Churchill thought. Churchill thought
the British Empire implied an order of the
world that would be safe and secure and that
it would be a major component of the future
safety and security of the world, and that
it would be good for the Indian people. Churchill’s
accusation made beautifully and often against
Gandhi and his friends is that they are upsetting
that.
Then Churchill got beat on that. In the course
of getting beat and as he was getting beat
Gandhi send a representative to Churchill,
to London, he was in London. His name was
G. D. Birla, B-I-R-L-A and by the way a word
about the greatness of Martin Gilbert. We
have some of the letters that are important
between Birla and Gandhi about Churchill from
the Gandhi papers, not from the Churchill
papers. These are not letters to Churchill.
Martin Gilbert looked everywhere. That's why
we know what I'm about to tell you. The man
was tireless. He was a machine of a good kind.
“Although he is no friend of our cause Churchill
is a great friend of India, and he wishes
us well, and we talked at length and then
he invited me to his home for a weekend and
we had a great time.” I produced that letter
in response to a historian named Jeff Jeffrey
Best who published that Churchill could not
bear the company of people of color. Churchill
admired very much Gandhi's standing up for
the Muslims and the untouchables and proud
to see that and congratulated him for that.
You know Gandhi was killed by a Muslim extremist.
So what their argument was about was that
Churchill thought that they were depriving
the world and India of a great good. It was
very hard for India for a long time. Lots
of death.
What was that? Did I say Muslim? I meant Hindu
extremist. The Hindus and Gandhi was a Hindu
didn't like him trying to make up with the
Muslims. I think he was living among Muslims
at the time and he was shot by a Hindu for
that. See, my boys are down there. I think
that’s what the argument was about.
I think myself that Gandhi was a great man,
but misguided about those things. I think
what was going on in retrospect one thinks,
what Andrew thinks about this because he's
written a lot about this kind of thing. I
think that the disease that has affected intellectual
classes in America beginning at about this
time and a bit before I think it was in the
intellectual classes in Britain too about
things like the Empire. I think there was
… They didn't have the spirit for it and
they were broken up some by the First World
War as they might have been, and I think they
didn't, they didn't believe in the mission
of Britain in the way Churchill did.
It's hard for anybody to write. Andrew is
about the only serious historian who writes
this way, taking seriously Churchill’s claims,
because they're beyond the pale now for anybody
to believe them. You have to be Andrew or
the president of Hillsdale College or Jim
Mahler who's not a historian and a few others.
What do the rest of them think? That was all
so long ago and different and he never did
catch up to it.
Charles Krauthammer says in a really brilliant
article he wrote about Churchill that Churchill
was a man of the 19th century. Well that's
not what I think. I don't think Churchill
was a man of a century, although there were
lots of things about the 19th century that
he liked. Yes sir.
Speaker 6: Doctor Arnn, your first question
AKA the difference between Chamberlain and
Obama I thought was extremely intriguing.
I wonder if you would comment on Churchill's
view of colonialism as opposed to constitutionalism,
and tell me if you think maybe the difference
between
Chamberlain and Obama was that Chamberlain
was not a Muslim?
Larry: I don't think Obama is a Muslim, but
I don't know. Remember, that's a question.
Like when you speculate … Obama has said
that he is not and there is that sentence
where he said he was one time, and if the
quote is accurate I think he said it as a
way to identify and show sympathy with people
who are Muslims. But the main point about
that is it's a reason why it's hard for me
to say that I think Obama means harm to the
country, because that's a statement about
his intentions. But if you try to account
for the facts that you see that idea is beginning
to suggest itself.
About colonialism and constitutionalism, so
here's what I think about it. I've actually
written about this now and about to be published,
but what I think is Churchill thought that
ability to govern oneself was coincident with
humanity and had nothing to do with color,
that races weren’t qualified or disqualified
to govern themselves. I can't find anywhere
where he said the contrary of that in many
places where he said that. I checked with
my living encyclopedia, Richard Langworth
about that, because he thought I was being
too generous at one point commenting on my
book about Churchill and Empire and maybe
I still am. I don't know, I think I changed
it some. But I said, do you, can you find
any place where Churchill said that the black
ones or the browns ones or the yellow ones
or the white ones are unqualified to govern
themselves. I mean I don't think there is
such a place.
What I think he did think was this. What's
going to happen if you have elections in Egypt
or Palestine? First of all, they’re surrounded
by hostility and tyranny and much influenced
by that. Second of all, they're divided among
themselves in powerful ways. I said to a senior
official in the White House at an important
moment one time. He said, “Do you believe
in freedom in Iraq,” and I said, “Yeah.”
He said, “But …” I said, “Well, isn't
it difficult?” He said, “Well, they want
it.” I said, “Gracious,” almost said
the man's name. I said, “Have you never
read the federalist papers?” That's all
about how hard these things are and how propitious
the conditions are here.
Churchill was aware that. That's basic political
science. How do you get a regime set up where
it’ll be stable and just to the weak and
the strong alike? How you’re going to do
that? Because that's pretty rare. In our own
case it’s influenced by this weird thing
about us which can never be repeated, and
that is a bunch of people from developed and
learned countries came over here to a wild
new place and got to start completely over.
They brought huge amounts of stuff with them
and they a built country, a great one eventually.
It was very hard for them to do it. In places
where the conditions are not like that maybe
they can't.
Remember Churchill's claim about India, is
a prudential claim. All of the factors that
I listed mattered to him. He, by the way,
he was in charge of Iraq for a while. He didn't
want to stay. His number two in command, Lawrence
of Arabia, didn't want to stay either. But
India was like this. We didn't just go conquer
it. We got it. It's gone very well. Things
are better there now. They accept us. We don't
rule them with an iron first. We don't need
to. Most of the policing and most of the defense,
almost all in fact is done by them. We are
introducing government institutions at the
provincial level that is teaching them the
practices of self-government. You know by
the way Indians today take pride in those
practices and that they have them. They didn't
get them from any time before Great Britain.
So colonialism if it was just in Churchill's
argument would be the seedbed of constitutionalism.
He gave a Fourth of July speech once in his
life and he said Fourth of July 1918, “By
the declaration of independence we lost an
empire,” meaning all this, here. “But
by it we've also preserved an Empire, because
we learned that people have the right to govern
themselves and the empire is an instrument
for that.”
Now that might not be. It’s a prudential
argument, it depends on a bunch of characteristics
being so. That means that Churchill didn't
think the British Empire should go anywhere.
By the way, if you ever look at a map, first
of all, if you look at the places where it
was, it was all over, but if you look at the
map of the places that were important to him
they go around the sea lanes. Churchill was
interested in that, great maritime power.
He thought British freedom was traceable back
to the English Channel. That's the point.
The reason it’s interesting today is because
we've got a problem how we’re going to deal
with parts of the world that are not free
but are powerful? Churchill's plan was the
British Empire is going to help manage some
of those places whether in key spots and make
the world better, in conjunction with the
United States. He wanted a wedding at Fulton
of the strength of America and the British
Empire and Commonwealth. Franklin Roosevelt
and Dwight Eisenhower were reluctant about
any affiliation with the Empire.
My only point is you can describe his plan
and you'd have to call it brilliant and deeply
learned and knowledgeable. There might not
be anything like the right plan today. It
didn't work then in the way he wanted it to.
But we need some plan like that because the
world is very dangerous and surely it would
start with being friends with our friends.
One more they say.
Speaker 7: If Obama is not a Muslim is he
an anti-colonialist?
Larry: If Obama is not a Muslim is he an anti-colonialist?
I think he said things like that. So explaining
the mind of Barack Obama, there's a good book
by the way called “I am the change” by
Charles Kesler, you should read that. What
you should do whenever you’re thinking about
anybody serious, and Obama is a very serious
man, is try to make a consistency in his thought
and you'll know that you’ve unlocked it
if you can uncover the good that they love.
What do they think?
Aristotle says, “Every action aims to the
good, every choice, every thought, everything.”
So you can understand Hitler. Hitler thought
that he could make a heaven on earth on the
basis of race, at last. It was partly like
this mystical Norse Aryan history, but it
was also scientific experiments to mess with
people's genes and to wipe out an entire people.
The communist, what are they thinking? They’re
thinking that at last we've got to the place
where we can take control of everything and
we can eliminate everything that's wrong,
we can fix it all. The socialists in Britain
in the end that's what they're saying. Here's
a claim in the Fabian Essays. The claim is
if you will just provide everybody with the
same and a sufficient income, everybody will
be a lot nicer to each other and much more
productive, because they won't have to worry
about grasping and just getting their own
anymore.
But where does that idea come from? Their
plan was to implement that flipping idea.
There had been trials of it by early socialists
and they had all collapsed, but nevermind,
we're going to, it's inevitable. They argue
that democratic politics have come to Britain,
therefore the people are going to rule and
they're going to elect us, and we are going
to implement a socialist regime and everybody's
going to love it, and up to step four every
word of that was an accurate prediction. That's
the point.
Let's instead of this because here's the way
of thinking if you think the way Churchill
did, if you think the way Thomas Jefferson
thought, here's what you’d think. You'd
think we're all here in this room. I know
a lot of you. Some of you are old friends.
I respect and admire you all as a bunch. I
think of you, when I think of you I think,
“These are steady people. They've got jobs.
They work. They go through the same struggles
I do. They've got kids, a lot of them. They
love those kids very much. They're going to
get old and die and that's sad. And they don't
always do as well as each other, and some
of that is chance.” This is life. We love
our life because we get a chance to live them.
You take one's children away and one's job
away, because we've got a guaranteed income,
and then one's conscience away, because if
every standard of right is evolving over time,
what do we mean by conscious except some form
of compliance or self-indulgence? Those are
the two alternatives. If you take those three
things away your conscience and your property
and your children, what's left of human life?
How do we get to live then? Somebody's going
to be living for us. Then the next step will
be bread for a purpose, will be bread without
the ambition to any other purpose.
I think when he was 25 years old I think I
know the place where it becomes manifest.
Winston Churchill saw that coming. I think
he fought his entire life to stop it. I think
he didn't win, except a lot he did, and there
isn't any record of anyone who fought against
that so well and explained so well.
Now you could say these trends are awesome
and they can't be stopped. But he resisted
that kind of thinking. Although he wrote a
lot about it and entertained the notion that
that is how the world had come to be, things
are so big now we can't control them. But
do you know what proves that that's not the
way of things? Because on the 28th of May
in the year 1940 there was one living man
with the ability to make that speech that
I just told you about, and that man was in
that place. Everything is different because
that happened. In other words, he proved the
truth of it himself with his own actions.
That's why no one must ever despair.